James Gunn just cause Marvel fans the
world over to breathe allowed collective
sigh and we're not quite sure if it's in
relief or dismay the director of the
guardians of the galaxy movies continues
to use part of his pandemic downtime to
chat with fans and filmmakers alike via
social media while gun has frequently
used such platforms to delight both with
quippy responses and insightful video
watch parties like one for guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 during which he shared
a treasure trove of fun facts about the
flick his latest Twitter interactions
have proven more than a little
bittersweet the first of them came when
Gunn took time to respond to one fans
inquiry about whether or not guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 had originally been
slated for a July 2020 release back in
January 2018 Gunn had shared on Twitter
that the third installment of the galaxy
saving heroes mini Marvel franchise
would arrive in 2020 but he didn't
specify when considering Marvel only
schedules a certain number of films per
year for a while it seemed too like
guardians 3 might have been scheduled
for a prime summer 2020 launch however
according to Gunn's recent tweet it
appears the release date of the hotly
anticipated sequel was actually even
sooner
he wrote original date for the release
of vol 3 was going to be May of this
year we would have been delayed because
of coronavirus god works in mysterious
ways
mysterious ways indeed in case you've
forgotten guardians of the galaxy vol
threes journey to the big screen has
been one fraught with drama in a now
infamous decision made in July 2018
executives at the Walt Disney Company
which owns Marvel Studios fired gun from
the picture in the wake of an online
controversy after past tweets of his
resurfaced and redeemed offensive a few
months and plenty of public outcry later
Disney rehired gun we like to thank the
company enjoyed its humble pie
[Music]
I like it I too am extraordinarily
humble but by then the in-demand
director had already booked a new gig
helming the reboot / sequel to DC's
Suicide Squad that meant volume three of
his beloved Marvel franchise would have
to be put on hold while that wait
continues to torment Marvel Cinematic
Universe devotees dying to dance once
again with star-lord and the gang it now
seems that even if Gunn and company had
gotten guardians of the galaxy vol 3
done on the original timeline we still
would have had to wait a little longer
to see it given the total shutdown of
just about every major film and
television production it's obviously
very unclear at this point exactly how
long fans will wait to get their peepers
on more Guardians goodness even major
theater chains like AMC don't seem to
have any clue when the film will
actually arrive in theaters the folks at
AMC recently tagged Gunn while
celebrating the guardians of the galaxy
franchise with a killer gift of Peter
quill busting some moves
dance-off fro me and you the problem was
that said tweet touted the return of gun
and the cast for vol 3 in 2021 it
appears that AMC was working with an old
MCU release schedule as Gunn graciously
pointed out in his own tweet he wrote
thanks for the love AMC Theaters
although we won't be in theaters until a
little after 2021 unless they've been
filming without me that'll hardly come
as a shock of course as we've known for
some time that guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 wouldn't shoot until Gunn was
finished with the Suicide Squad which
fortunately wrapped prior to all the
kovat 19 related delays Gunn is
reportedly editing the DC flick while in
quarantine too so barring unexpected
setbacks his trilogy capping guardians
of the galaxy movie should still shoot
on schedule unfortunately it's unknown
when volume 3 will actually begin
production Gunn recently shot down
reports that the movie would begin
production in February 2021 but even if
cameras start rolling several months
before that once rumored start date
instead of after a 2021 release seems
impossible given how long the
post-production process takes as it is
Marvel brass has yet to slot guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 into a firm release
date it also appears neither Marvel nor
Disney have an open release date in
place for early 2022 so there's really
no telling when guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 might finally hit theaters check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]